hello and welcome to the studio symphony
in you from Brazil and so I really have
to get something going into to cut above
2400 but currently I simply don't feel
well while playing blitz online that one
better feels like it boils my brain have
really troubled to to focus on the games
so maybe and I hope this gets better
here in this game and get Symphony new
now playing this man the solid line oops
gender in the Slav no lousy form don't
see this that often usually um a black
players are prefer to play Knightly form
themselves okay mm what to do and
develop here
this type of position happens quite
often from the Slav White has some the
better Center and should be um should be
better but it's not easy to play because
black asses this constant counter play
against the against the center with its
pieces yeah we cannot take d for now do
2nite seen for what what what's the deal
here Quincy 556 and the queen is gone
and yes we sacrifices the queen and that
this way okay it still requires some
technical precision here probably let's
see how to do it keep one I guess it's
got some minor piece rook and pawn which
is off not that easy to convert
okay but now i get if Ivan ok also it's
got the deep on now it's still hard to
believe yeah i should i think i should
have reconsidered this anyway i'm going
to not play you five now which i
originally wanted to do but then is
Bishop there from age seven gets active
quite a bit so let's not do that and
just see if i can maybe just win the
deep on
okay let's see that c5 is not so easily
happening yeah it's still not not so
easy from a technical point of view
I would like to play Queen B to Queen F
to attack that pawn and get rid of the
night just to win the pond down it's not
not so easy tho opieop h3 that's always
95 one really takes a very long time in
might be 6 i'm not sure where he wants
to go with this might be sick psycho
Knight a5 and all night ii five I can
also just take on your six I think I'll
do that actually this is looking pretty
clean yeah that's pretty clean the
bishop stays bad now on on h7
we're taking you six him
check black resigns yeah i blundered
Queen deform I mean normally black
players go here and prevent prevent you
forward there is there is this thing and
we should give white a slight advantage
yet this and now I have got this in
Bishop f4 now 92 is I guess a good move
to go to see for I know he blundered
with Queen D forcibly and probably
overlooking that I have this move I
don't know this is the queen the thing
is I'm not sure about the technical side
I think this is okay probably five and
now this to trade of the bishop that's
certainly good and now I took it and now
yeah this is there this is an important
moment the alternative and my original
idea was to play you five but I wasn't
so sure because all of a sudden that
Bishop is opened up and probably is
still a good young and therefore Queen
g4 yeah this is probably a lot more
powerful but I think this is a good
technical move let's say I don't see em
black hand holding this particular not
now and now this is this a swinging for
white yeah okay Queen takes d4 sometimes
it's just one move we just didn't see
that the Queen was getting getting
trapped basically okay thanks for
watching